- I could see this being a new trend,
along with like a sexy
bikini and stuff like that.
- My mom always wore
prom gloves while driving
because they protected
her skin from the sun
as her arms were out here.
- Growing up I'd be really excited
when I'd see these tins expecting
some delicious, buttery cookies.
I'd open it up and I'd see
just a bunch of sewing needles,
and spools of thread, and pin cushions.
It safe, it's cute and
round, and it's durable.
- These are super big visors meant to
shield your entire face from the sun.
She keeps one in the car to protect
herself from sun damage
and also wrinkling.
You could wear this while going on a hike,
committing a heist.
My mom wears this a lot
when she's gardening.
It's so versatile.
- They would fill in a sock with rice,
and microwave it.
And it's great to use as a heating pad.
Some daughters use it for period cramps.
They're great for
stomachaches and backaches.
It's basically a cure all.
- She would take my old T-shirts
and turn them into either dish rags
or floor rags.
She cleaned the floor,
she cleaned the sink,
she cleaned the car, she
cleaned the washing machine.
She would cut it down into little squares
depending on what she needed to clean up.
- My mom and dad taught me
this when I was really young.
It's just wetting a paper towel
and putting it over some rice.
This allows you to
actually resteam the rice.
It tastes a lot better,
it maintains the texture.
It's not as dry.
- My mom goes out a lot with umbrellas,
especially like to theme parks.
You see this a lot at like swap meets,
grocery store shopping,
picking up your kids.
Asian moms love protecting their skin
because they don't want to look old.
You would think it's
raining, but it's not.
It's only the sun.
- Now that you've seen
some Asian mom hacks,
what kind of hacks does your mom use?